je pense qu'ils ont vraiment vraiment
bien fait de lancer cette action
[Musique]
il est midi deux femmes s'arrêtent
devant ces tournesols de Van Gogh estimé
à 85 millions d'euros
et les asperges de soupe à la tomate
devant un public médusé
qu'est-ce qui a le plus de valeur l'art
ou la vie c'est une séquence qui a
beaucoup fait réagir et on peut se poser
plein de questions par rapport à cette
séquence la première c'est qu'est-ce qui
conduit des jeunes gens à des extrémités
pareilles combien d'années il a fallu de
de déni à regarder ailleurs d'une
certaine manière pour qu'ils en viennent
à faire ça et puis on peut se dire
pourquoi est-ce que ça fait plus parler
qu'on s'attaque d'une certaine manière
même si c'est seulement à une vitre à
une représentation de la nature plutôt
que de la destruction de la nature
elle-même